i used to struggle reading the quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app i never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for ios
and android and build your habit with
the quran right now assalamu alaikum
guys hope you guys are winning charlotte
the game the game what game am i talking
about you guys know brothers sisters in
jahili are you say listen to the game 50
cent g unit all these kind of the whole
click i used to listen to them a lot
they had a big influence in my lifestyle
the way i lived the way i fought the way
i operated uh but it's very interesting
to hear about him as a muslim myself 10
years ago coming to islam and to see
that individuals like the game that you
would never think to yourself
subhanallah you know what they really
come to islam the lifestyle that they
live of you know money cars girls and
everything like that well yes they do
and why do they do that well here's what
the game the rapper had to say so um
somebody sent this to me on his story on
instagram he is the picture for the holy
quran and it says couldn't wait to get
home and open you yeah now before um the
story like before this one the other
ones were talking a bit about um which i
could i didn't get a chance to
screenshot them but he was talking more
about people who are snaky towards him
you know who are kind of maybe
backstabbed and he was giving those kind
of um talk so you can see that people
who are up there brothers and sisters we
always think like when we're watching i
used to watch their music videos of
girls and all this haram stuff etc you
really think like wow man this is the
lifestyle but you really ask yourself a
question what do they really go through
when all the lights are turned off and
the music
has been turned off what is their real
lifestyle and this shows you brothers
and sisters that allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala every soul is going to be tested
now there's a verse in the quran
subhanallah
mentions i want to read it yeah
inshallah allah says
and by the soul and the one who made it
well
then inspired it with ins with it
instincts of evil and piety success is
really
attained by him who purifies it and
failure is really suffered by whom him
who pollutes it this is very interesting
because allah is saying and this
connects beautifully to this that we are
all born with instincts of good and bad
that's like just imagine i don't know if
i say two cups or one cup here so
if we have a cup and half of the cup
argument's sake it's fresh water and the
top half without being mixed is dirty
water we are
we are created with both of them now
it's upon you if you add more dirty
water to it it's going to pollute it
it's going to make it worse meaning your
evil nature is going to um increase and
that's what allah says we do not guide
the sinning people like people who are
transgressing and transgressing however
if you add clean water into that dirty
water what do you think is going to
happen to that polluted water it's going
to what purify it and what does allah
say subhanallah say success is really
attained by whom him who purifies it so
you have instincts of good and bad you
can't come on the day of judgment and
say you know no no no you had good and
bad even when i was a non-muslim i would
have instincts of doing evil and i would
have instincts of doing good in certain
scenarios so my message like to all of
you guys watching this as well is number
one do not look at celebrities or
rappers or whoever they may be and think
to yourself that they are living this
amazing life and then no no deep down
brother and sister especially when
you're rich you have a lot of fake
people around you even the person you
want to marry yeah you don't even know
if they're with you for the right
reasons or the wrong reasons so for the
game to come home imagine he has all of
those things money cars goes anything
and he makes a instagram story scene and
having a picture of the quran and saying
i can't wait home to come
and open you what does that say that he
truly finds solace peace tranquility in
the kitab of allah and it is what like
allah says in the quran only in the
remembrance of your lord your hearts
find peace and how else can you find
remembrance except by his kitab brothers
and sisters
ask allah to open the quran to you the
quran is a treasure of many treasures
put connect yourself to the quran if a
disbeliever which i don't know if he's a
believer or not like game who's involved
in in in the rap industry and haram etc
can find peace and solace in the quran
what about us believers brothers and
sisters ask allah to connect you to the
quran allow you to memorize the quran
and to live and die by it that's all i
would have to say inshallah maybe you
guys can tag the game inshallah and send
this to him maybe he can see it and if
he's not a muslim i would highly highly
encourage him to in which he is reading
the quran but also dua which is a prayer
ask god almighty to guide
and you are already on that path that's
all i have to say brother and sisters
inshallah may allah guide him and guide
us inshaallah and make us among those
who would die
till next time salaam alaikum
warahmatullahi